when your dominguez having a tough time
in the match but with a lovely comeback
in the last blitz game really sweet
tactics yes we've seen him play many
times before and play brilliantly the
nearest not been easy this match Levana
it seems very confident what was the
difference today
I think he's he's playing very well
somehow I was I think I have I got good
positions in general maybe except one or
two games were but from the beginning
but in general I was not doing so bad
but then just spending too much time and
sometimes in times roll I was just
ruining some some good positions time
trouble is a factor here of course it's
rapid in and blitz is the novelty of the
position that you're facing each day
contributing to that time trouble yeah
thanks for sure for especially in the
Blitz game for example if you if you're
unlucky and you get something which you
didn't prepare at all
like like it happened to me my first
blitz game then it's really tough
because you have to start thinking for a
move one and it becomes really I mean it
can become really unpleasant
what do you chase is coming back in this
match what are you thinking about
tomorrow well it's obviously not not so
good I mean I I guess I don't have so
many chances but anyway I'll play I'll
try to do my best I'll try to play some
interesting games and to to keep having
some some fun we look forward to it
good luck